bon vous allez vous moquez de moi j'ai
découvert il ya seulement un peu plus
d'un mois que vous m'envoyer des
messages sur un stade des messages
privés je veux dire pour ça en fait foi
plaidant le bouton demande d'invitation
et là il ya toutes les conversations qui
apparaissent mais en fait avant j'avais
que des conversations de groupe
donc je comprenais pas trop ce que
c'était je pensais que c'était que pour
faire des groupes etc
mais en fait pas du tout en fait ya
plein de gens qui peuvent envoyer des
messages en perso et je ne savais pas et
oui on a beau être un gros gros flop
c'est la honte mais à chaque fois je
raconte ça quelqu'un il fait poteau mais
tu déconnes quoi il prend de haut et
roger le droit de découvrir les choses
et de parfois ne pas être à la pointe de
la dernière nouveauté s'il vous plaît en
fait les seules fois où je parle à des
gens par installer des gens que je suis
et donc du coup ils n'apparaissent pas
dans le truck demande d'invitation je
peux comment s'appellent les a pas
raison truc de base bref tout ça pour
dire que j'ai découvert il ya un peu
plus d'un mois
cet onglet l'a donc maintenant je
m'amuse à parfois vous répondez à vos
messages a parfois m autorise par
exemple pour les tubes de l'été là et
heureusement que j'ai découvert ça avant
de faire les îles de l'été parce que
sinon je n'aurais rien mais instaurer du
tout et c'est dommage parce que ça fait
vu le truc est tout en bas et j'ai donc
trouvé un délire qui est trop drôle vous
êtes plein à vous amuser à créer des
groupes alors il ya certains de ces
groupes qui sont créés juste pour la
blague il mettre que des personnalités
dedans et à d'autres de ces groupes où
il ya genre cinq six potes de lycée
dedans et il invite des personnalités en
plus dans le groupe
mais ils font comme si les avait jamais
invités et eux parlent dans le groupe
depuis genre des jours et des jours
voire des mois
c'est vraiment leur conversation de
potes officiel mais que je peux voir
mois puisqu'ils m'ont invité au tout
début quand ils l'ont créé sais c'est
qu'on veut là que j'adore rejoindre
parce que ça ne s'y attendent pas du
tout et du coup quand arrive c'est
vraiment marrant souvent ça crée des
trucs soit des réactions un peu haut
mais what the fuck soit tout l'inversé
vous me parler normalement comme si on
avait toujours été potes et j'adore je
trouve ça génial cette ambiance voilà je
découvre un truc un peu tard mais mieux
vaut tard que jamais ces partis rejoigne
aux quelques groupes j'espère qu'il y en
a puisque des fois on n'a pas beaucoup
des fois il y en a pas trop bon moment
et il y en a d'autres plus tard mais
c'est savary quoi cyprien un mix m flo
et oli et s'était envoyé salle elle est
parfaite
cherbaka vraiment trop gentil je tombe
sur quoi là je vais tomber sur des trucs
glauque est ce qu'ils se battent à la
temps c'est quoi la jeunesse de
conversations pourquoi elles existent
way match donc sur moi je tends quelques
jours oui c'est horrible espionne déjà
en quoi un showroom invités vous étonnez
pas c'est pas du voyeurisme ce que je
fais je suis invitée dans la
conversation je suis participants j'ai
le droit
je suis un peu silencieux donc julie
apparemment il ya mathieu qui enquête
sur elle mais elle est pas en kit sur
luis attend vos messages
on va envoyer un message julie pourquoi
t'es pas en kiff sûr
sur mathieu il est à fond sur toi lui
apparemment j'ai vu au bahut
je suis plus jeune c'est officiel je ne
suis plus jeune là ils sont en train de
répondre
ils sont en train de répondre à temps on
veut quand même savoir si mathieu et
julie vont finir ensemble ou pas quoi on
veut savoir le dernier ragot c'est pas
julie c'est lui zac est actif sur
mathieu bah ouais je suis pas un qui
faisait six mois
ah merde ah oui c'est luisa oh là là je
pas foutu de savoir où et marquer le
pseudo par rapport au message je croyais
que c'était en dessous mais c'est au
dessus j'aime fatigue bon allez suivante
et fera way s'est trouvé des combes un
peu cool
qu'est ce que c'est que ça billy royaume
voyez par exemple c'est une couche je
suis dedans mais ils ont écrit mais des
kilomètres de message n'a aucun sens
soirée du 28 à temps il ya une soirée il
ya une soirée on prévient pas attendez
c'est cool je suis invité à une soirée
le vin de suite est ce que toi tu as une
soirée le 28 je suis pas sûr excusez moi
vous avez l'adresse ou quoi pour la
soirée le 28 daniel exode qui sont
excités la haye les gars c'est sacha
c'est pas moi qui l'a affectée mais qui
se tape la cruche comme chanel et 10 q
je me fait recaler s'épousent h et tu
crois vraiment que c'est vrai petit mais
luisa je veux juste td quoi avec avec
mathieu ya faut pas me repousser comme
ça tu me dis si c'est trop intime et
tout et je me mêle de ce qui me regarde
pas peut-être c'est le cas mais c'est
bienveillant de ma part en tout cas un
mirador supérieur à bye bye attend quoi
attentant pardon vous osez m'inviter
dans une confia ce nom on est dans le
non respect maintenant vous et moi ça me
dégoûte
attendez on a des news de luisa roues
mais c'est mon ex et je n'aime pas ah
merde
ah merde son ex la gaffe j'adore l'usl
en a rien à [ __ ] c'est comme si
j'avais été toujours leurs amis c'est
touchant à la fois des nouvelles de la
soirée du 28 ch et qui alors sadiv donne
l'adresse à ce quizz évident [ __ ]
commencez pas là des cinq sens où
j'adore je vous jure je sais pas si
c'est un délire mal placé ou pas mais
j'adore j'ai l'impression que je suis
pote depuis des années avec ces gens
alors qu'on ne se connaît pas si génial
et c'est quoi ce délire d'avoir son
téléphone en cours mais qu'est ce que
vous faites là mais c'est nous c'est
nous les youtuber qui vous incitons à
faire ce genre de choses là les jeunes
ça pas du tout la dre s'il vous plaît je
dois demander à ma mère de m'emmener
voilà alors bye bye soir à mirador
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont répondu la pause
justifier alors pardon lucas je commence
plutôt bien
c'est réglé oups il va est supérieur à
mirador maintenant et ben merci un peu
de respect pour moi tu meurs préféré bon
pour notre conversation un peu la dst mg
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils passent le bac
ils passent le bac courage pour le bac
là tout le monde travailler travailler
travailler travailler sinon vous finirez
par ne plus arriver à articuler à dire
correctement les mots comme moi j'espère
que cela va donner la force
mdr je suis choquée mais merci merci
squeeze tu es un bon voilà frais merci
squeeze tu gères la faf la ferme est
installé travailler là squeeze l'homme
qui vient au jdm pour te crées dessus
parce que tu sur ton téléphone et le
travail est inquiète on va travailler
merci c'est drôle qui s'excuse d'être
sur un stade je suis vraiment vote d'un
rond suivante papa qu'est ce que vous
faites à gagner cette vidéo il travaille
et d'ailleurs qu'est ce que vous faites
allez d'autres combats s'il vous plaît
l'armée jambes ou sur pattes sympa le
nom ya toujours des noms plus ou moins
originaux qu'un peu tout dans les noms
j'ai lu vite fait il passe le bac mais
j'ai besoin de faire du voyeurisme et
d'un autre côté ils m'ont invité dans la
combe
ils doivent s'ouvrir à la possibilité
que les gens qui l'ont invité dans la
cause puisse lire ce qu'il vient
d'écrire ne l'invité pas dans des coups
vous n'avez pas envie qu'on lise
allez courage pour le mâcon d'un tour
donne tout on y va on étudie on
travaille je suis chiant
owen francks et le bakoye la banque
faceo et verdi j'atteins vous me
répondez que je souhaitais pas de ça me
tue genre imaginez c'est vraiment celui
ci qui nous a produit [ __ ] tu imagines
tu imagines c'est lui jean et nous a
souhaité bonne chance pour le bac on n'a
pas le droit de le rater après ça ça
veut dire on va devoir travailler comme
des malades là
est ce que georges heymans et squeeze là
qui nous parle mais que fais tu dont là
je travaille je sais on dirait pas mais
je travaille les mongols 2.0 sucre ou
pays
c'est drôle que non ah merde perrine
[ __ ] on a tous une pèlerine dans un
groupe de pointe a d'ailleurs dans le
mien c'est moi la perrine hashtags je
suis père et moi je crois à temps des
sondages il vient d'arriver on va avoir
l'adresse pour la soirée du 28 on va
pouvoir y aller 45 minutes de paris au
haut à ay ay ay malheureusement j'ai le
mariage de natsu ce jour là je pourrai
pas venir mais je vous souhaite de bien
vous amuser le tout dans la modération
amusez-vous sereinement tranquillement
sans tomber dans l'excès bisous et
vendre mes services a avait pas ranger
créer un business cunha mamao
regardez ils ont créé une nouvelle date
de si longtemps elle remonte jusqu'à qu
elles auront jusqu'en avril c'est génial
attendait bonjour désolé j'ai pas suivi
vous avez créé la conf pourquoi j'adore
jouer perso qui est très premier degré
vous casser les couilles à changer de
nom dedans yaggeur m bape et la
champions league emmanuel macron neymar
pogba et aurélien d'ikea les couilles
d'ajouter la daronne à julien vous êtes
des ghana on est tous pareils c'est
l'accouchement rock au générique d'un
tiers sa dans le même genre on fait de
ce genre de vannes avec maxence etc
j'en étais dans un bar à jour et tu
pouvais envoyer une photo sur les écrans
et fallait qu'elle ait des aubes votent
pour eux pour qu'elle passe à l'écran il
y avait jean une file d'attenté et on a
mis une photo de la maman de maxence et
comme on était dix on a tous validés et
s'afficher partout sur les écrans et ou
pleurer de rire et toujours des vannes
de gamme est ce que c'est de trouver ça
drôle pas spécialement alors on a des
nouvelles de perrine ta gueule tu
quittes lacombe
tu m'a vexé alors la coupe queen yamano
mdr désolé du dérangement si ces idiots
ils ont fait un groupe et le tour ajouté
oh non c'est pas cool ça
je croyais que ce fait vous êtes
tellement mignon à croire si vous avez
vraiment dérangé ou quoi c'est tout
c'est évident qu'on s'en fout invités
qui vous voulez dans vos gros pasta y'a
pas de soucis oh désolé banon ça l'est
pas attends je lui ai envoyé de photo
[Musique]
je pourrais faire ça toute la journée en
fait y'a un truc c'est que ça me fait
trop plaisir de vous parler comme ça
dans des sphères tout petit y'a pas une
que 200 personnes ou je sais pas quoi on
est vraiment dans une cour où on est
quatre c'est super drôle c'est génial
allez on y va on continue avec la
maturité à 5 vous fait pour moi alors là
je suis désolé mais c'est quand même un
groupe qui a été créé pour moi trop cool
on est enfin entre gens matures ici ça
fait du bien
je ris pour rien ça me ça me fait rire
je le fait d'arriver dans une course
comme ça ça me fait ya plus de groupe 1
c'est la merde là les gens je suis en
train de galérer à trouver des groupes
j'ai passé je fais je suis pas si
populaire tabou et demain il ya un stage
bats les couilles les oreilles m'envahit
moi les gars dommage weight of à mes
attentes j'ai pas de coffre
ça m'étonne pas de la conversation
tabouret ça m'étonne pas du tout chip
quoi dire je serai forcément drôle tout
ce qu'il a dit mais bien demain tu te
lèves d'un nouveau pied avec des
nouvelles ambitions et tu te dis c'est
aujourd'hui que je vais trouver du
travail tu traverses la rue et sûrs
rentrent c'est nul je t'ai envoyé
squeeze l'antenne gros mais passe de la
thune bâtard c'est comme ça que vous
voyez vous n'êtes qu'une bande de
profiteurs vous voyez comme un
porte-monnaie ambulance et sa wii est
mignon non je rigole je t'aime mdr t'es
le meilleur
à écouter on tape un kebab quand tu veux
comme tu veux gros tu crois je vais
faire quoi en fait là je commence une
game se faire c'est même plus avancée
que je fais ces enveloppes dans son père
wahou [ __ ] mais c'est un bon concept
ça va faire un blog dans son père à
bonne idée mais devenait youtube heures
plus tard faites nous rêver juste besoin
d'un endroit de merde 93 la cul sale
[ __ ] mais écoutez je sais que c'est dur
mais ne faites pas ça vous allez
regretter 100% des fois c'est évident ne
maltraités plus jamais aucune manette de
la sorte
ok ça coûte de l'argent et vous le
regretterez travailler à la place à
temps en temps une vidéo pour toi ce
coup-ci hockey me balance je suis sûr
qu'il a fait ça au moins 200 fois il
maîtrise trop il maîtrise trop
l'ouverture du volet le lancer dans
l'herbe et de tri seront les gars vous
êtes dispo pour la soirée du 28 ou pas
vous c'est quoi la soirée du 28 squeeze
on va ramener tellement de gens à cette
soirée et sont pas prêts dans l'autre
coup on va y aller vous êtes si nombreux
bon écoute et amis je scrawl jeu ce
qu'on n'y a plus de groupe avec que des
messages individuels et je vais pas
faire une vidéo sur les messages
individuels cesser souvent les jeunes
membres des trucs personnels où ils ont
pas forcément envie de se retrouver en
vidéo
donc on va éviter et ben écoutez c'est
la fin de cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
aller mais s'il vous a plu j'ai trouvé
ça très bien rentrés amusant puisque
vous aurez compris délire je trouve ça
vraiment rigolo ce truc de un tarif dans
la con et tu fais comme si c'était
normal et que c'est tes potes étouffe
tout ça marrant et les gens jouent le
jeu la plupart du temps c'est ça qui est
drôle
allez je vous dis à bientôt dans une
vidéo en live un groupe un stade qui
sait et puis portez vous bien j'espère
que mes exams se sont bien passées ou
qui se passeront bien s'ils sont pas
finies je fais plein de bisous je vous
dis chaque iep et agressive c'est tout
faux
[Musique]